[Music]
[Applause]
Mark kisler Denver Post columnist oh you
were breathing fire there kids
um when the punishment came out what was
uh what was your reaction yesterday when
you heard that Matt ishby is not going
to be disciplined and the Jokers find 25
000 but not suspended
play on everybody we've got game five
you know I I got to give ishp credit
though
um
in a in a must-win game for the Suns
he earned a point for his team so uh I
think coach money should probably give
him a letter jacket
okay but when you saw it what did you
think was going to happen
when I saw
um uh I I thought Joker would be fine
but not suspended I was frankly
surprised that there was talk uh that he
would be suspended I mean he elbowed the
guy but but but it's to be inserted
himself into the game he's the owner he
can do that
um uh you know ESP didn't want to give
him the ball and then it should be sold
the call so
um
no harm no foul I think that's the
technical yeah I think the commissioner
was just trying to get through this and
not suspend him therefore we're not
focusing on the owner's role in this and
I and I like it for trying to keep the
peace in the NBA that hey don't go into
the stands or don't touch anybody or
throw an elbow in there and then we
don't talk about the owner's role in
this but I I do think the owner should
have been disciplined in this situation
I just don't think the commissioner
wants this to drag into tonight's game
uh I agree with you entirely
um if Joker gets suspended
um every fan in the rocky mountain
region feels persecuted like uh the NBA
wants KD to play LeBron or Steph in the
Western Conference Finals
um my reaction at the time it was hey if
anybody should be suspended here it
should be the owner uh kick him out
until he learns how to behave
um he he can sit wherever he wants it's
his team but when the ball comes goes
into the stands it's not his ball well
you might think it's his ball yeah but
if you want to wrestle with the player
then that's on you this is what I'm
thinking I don't know if the Phoenix
Suns owner is going to be there tonight
but I would get Joker's two brothers and
have them sit on either side of him what
do you think
yeah
hooker told me once I was kidding
about
um going up against LeBron James and you
know I was kiddingly hey Joker are you
intimidated and jumper looked at me said
I am only intimidated and threatened of
one man in the entire world and that is
my big brother and so if you have
chunkers big brother sex to Matt ishp
tonight I guarantee you Matt this B
would be on his best behavior do we get
the nobody cares about us or covers Us
or watches us do you get the oboe is me
with uh nuggets or nuggets fans
oh absolutely I mean we're we're in the
lost time zone and so uh you know we
feel like we're a flyover City that do I
care no I'm looking out my window right
now at beautiful Colorado Mountains so
it doesn't bother me if if if if New
York or Boston or LA's your thing that's
great but yes fans do feel like
um the league would rather see LeBron or
KD uh go win a championship rather than
the Joker in the Denver Nuggets but
they've also had early exits here mark
from the playoffs oh sure so like we
don't invest in them because we don't
know if it's real or not is that a fair
assessment that uh from nationally
looking in locally
I I think it's a totally fair assessment
and I think it's a fair assessment that
uh you know Jokers scores 53 in game
four and that's not enough so does Joker
have enough help uh to be a uh for the
Nuggets to be truly a legitimate
Championship Contender does it irritate
the Nuggets I know it irritates coach
Malone he's only mentioned about 47
times whether sons are favored to come
out of the West for a region and that's
that's a little passive aggressive way
of saying nobody respects us he's Mark
kislin Denver Post columnist if you
could pick the Nuggets opponent next
round
if they got through this round who do
you want
the Warriors because I like San
Francisco
but but here here's what's important to
the Nuggets is the for the next round
the Nuggets really can't lose either
they have to go through LeBron they have
to go knock off the king or they'd have
to go through the Warriors and knock off
the defending champs and then those
legitimate questions are the nuggets for
real could be eliminated or dissipated
because they would face NBA through NBA
royalty in the Western Conference Finals
either way I'm wondering about where
Denver ranks with their duo with Booker
and KD Lebron and A.D
uh Tatum and brown Harden and embed
where would you put Denver on that list
well Jamal Murray's not gonna be happy
with me but I probably put them last I I
I you know without re litigating the MVP
I think Joker's the best basketball
player in the world I truly do believe
that he just put up 53 points in a
playoff game that's pretty impressive
the Nuggets problem is he you know he's
Batman who is Joker's Robin Jamal Murray
wants to be but sometimes in this series
I think you've seen Jamal Murray try a
little too hard to be that guy and not
distribute the ball enough they need the
Nuggets need more for Michael Porter Jr
and sometimes in this offense he kind of
gets lost
yeah we're year three of this it just
feels like they're light rock at some
times I need them to be heavy metal you
know Porter yeah yeah yeah you know
we'll play a little John Denver Dan well
it might be Christopher Cross or
somebody like that Air Supply
Whatever Gets You Through the day we're
all right with that all right uh before
I let you go uh did Russell Wilson get a
hall pass does he get a hall pass for
year one in Denver
no he did not he he did not get a hall
pass at all I was surprised you know
we're a happy little city out here man
but but but Broncos fans are sick and
tired of the losing and and they pointed
fingers right at Russ and they felt like
Russ cared more about his brand than he
did winning football games I think Sean
Payton will change that though
good to talk to you keep the peace play
nice tonight okay
I'll try all right Mark kisler Denver
Post columnist